To solve this equation, we want to undo the division by 2. We want to clear the
fraction, so we multiply by 2. Notice this is one whole fraction. I can reduce
the 2's that appear in the numerator and the denominator. I'm left with 3 times
the quantity a minus 7. Now, we want to clear the grouping so we can distribute
this positive 3 to each term. 3 times a is 3 a, and 3 times negative 7 is
negative 21. Adding 21 to both sides, we get 3 a equals negative 15. So, for the
solution, a is equal to negative 5. Remember, just like all the other equations,
we can check our answer. I can plug in negative 5 for a, and this result should
be negative 18. Negative 5 minus 7 is negative 12, 3 times negative 12 is
negative 36. And at negative 36 divided by 2 is negative 18. So our answer, a
equals negative 5, does check.